President Obama is sending thousands of
US troops to West Africa to fight the
outbreak of Ebola they'll construct
treatment centers and provide medical
training to healthcare workers and local
communities but is it really a good idea
to send soldiers to provide this sort of
aid here are three reasons why
militarizing humanitarian aid is a very
bad idea humanitarian aid must be
perceived as neutral and not driven by
political or military objectives using
the military in a humanitarian crisis
works against that and potentially
instigates further unrest attacks
against humanitarian personnel have been
rising over the past decade precisely
because of a perceived blurring of
humanitarian political and military
goals and our track record in Africa
warrants such skepticism over the past
six years the US military has expanded
its troop presence in Africa via
humanitarian missions that are
specifically designed to establish
points of entry for future military
missions local communities face a hell
of a bind if they don't accept hope from
the military they run the risk of losing
out a much-needed humanitarian aid
thatta roads the trust needed to
establish a working relationship between
aid workers and local communities
militarized aid is often backed by
massive budgets the Department of
Defense has already allocated 1 billion
dollars to fight Ebola the pressure to
spend massive amounts is often coupled
with pressure to achieve short-term
political goals that in turn translates
into ineffective use of funds
many politicians who support militarized
aid claim that the military is the only
institution capable of handling the
humanitarian crisis at hand if this is
true and and too often it is it
highlights the neglect of civilian-led
programs that are more likely to
actually get the job done by constantly
relying on the military for humanitarian
efforts we're stifling efforts to grow
civilian-led organizations that can
handle the complicated logistics
necessary to address large-scale
humanitarian crises